hello YouTube my new crystal ball don't
ask me why I bought it I'm gonna try to
talk pretty quick because I know my
videos can tend to be on the long side
so you know me I let my hair get out of
control again so I think we should
probably fix that now and there you go
that's how I do my hair thank you very
much to Annette she has been the one
that's been cutting my hair throughout
the years the name of this video is
called subscriber Sunday and the reason
I will get to in a little bit but in
this video I want to do a couple things
I'm gonna answer some questions that
people have been leaving down in the
comments section I want to give you guys
an update on to some things that have
been going on with my life and my
channel in general and I want to talk
about some cool ways that me and you
guys can talk a little bit better and
interact because that's the cool thing
about YouTube some people have some
comments on an older video asking me if
I finished dental school and yes I did I
graduated in May of 2013 and I did a
one-year residency in the Bronx which I
finished in July 2014 I just got my
dental license in New York so yeah
everything's ready to go
I have been taking a little bit of a
mental break away from work and
everything because I've been in school
my entire life and just wanted to step
away from everything for a little bit
and relax getting to the subscribers
Sunday thing it takes me a little while
to do tutorial videos so I want to do
something where it's a little easier for
me to kind of edit things and do
something quicker for subscribers Sunday
which I might do once a month I read
some p.o box mails that I've gotten in
my new peel box
read comments and questions that you
guys leave down in the comment section
maybe do some live shows where I answer
questions or just talk to you answer
some calls and just give a whole bunch
of thanks and shout outs to my
subscribers you guys for everything that
you've given me because my channel is
where it is today because of you I know
I don't mention this very often but my
channel has almost 400,000 subscribers
now with over 120 million views that's a
pretty amazing feat in my opinion I
never thought that my channel will be
what it is today so thank you guys
everything I mentioned in a video a
while back that I had a Rob's phone
channel and I have been updating that
channel more regularly I put out about
four or five videos in the last month
and a half or so one of them were
actually read the first mail that I got
to my P o box says thanks for the gift
box
origami video thanks so much Jose I
really appreciate you sending me the
letter a video of me juggling and asking
if you guys want to see for all you
people who are wondering if I still
solve the Rubik's Cube yes I put a
Rubik's Cube solving video on that
channel so be sure to check it out and
subscribe if you want to see little more
also I really appreciate it if you guys
checked out my Facebook I kind of update
that a little bit more and I have been
getting some feedback from you guys I
got some comments and pictures from you
guys showing me some stuff that you've
done from my channel and I really think
that's cool as you guys know for Rob's
world I had an introduction and I've
been having my friend from YouTube help
me out with it I want you to check it
out it's not quite done yet but it's
going to be finished pretty soon and I'm
going to put it probably in the
beginning of my tutorial videos not
every single video that I do from that
introduction design I've actually
designed a new t-shirt and you guys may
have seen this t-shirt that I have at
the district line store but I have a
rose world shirt and I think that's
pretty cool also as one of my
subscribers said one video a month isn't
enough maybe you could do one every two
weeks and I agree I think that's a great
thing maybe I can do two tutorial videos
per month and one subscriber Sunday or
update video so what do you guys think
of that leave me a comment in the
comment section below and let me know if
you think it's a good idea just a few
more things and I'll let you go okay I
bought my tickets to VidCon 2015 on July
23rd to the 25th the 25th is actually my
brother Rick's birthday so I'm going to
be visiting him as well don't forget
about my brother Walters channel that
you can check out bye
this link right here and at the vidcom
convention I would like to hand out
things that I've made like Oregon
boomerangs crossbows maybe if I don't
get arrested for dangerous weapons
boomerangs transforming ninja stars
whatever things like that and also give
away t-shirts not only give away stuff
at VidCon but I'd also like to do some
giveaways for my subscribers as well and
for some people who might want to just
get stuff that I've made and maybe sign
or something I might put it on my
district line store that way you guys
can get it easily that way thank you
very much I'd also like to give a big
thanks to YouTube they've been really
helpful with helping me manage my
channel and set things up so I promise
I'm gonna make more videos don't hijack
my channel one more summery check out my
Rob's poem Facebook district line store
let me know what you guys think of this
video subscribe to Sunday and have fun
watching some little videos that I
filmed and I'll see you next time don't
forget it huh don't forget it but don't
forget to get the big don't forget again
don't forget this is why I can't not
make videos for three months because it
takes me hours to talk about it real
ninja star sub buddy with your brothers
and sisters are they shy yeah we're all
gathered right here oh my baby
yeah close oh look at that this is
hugging you
hey hey okay I'll just eat outside then
yeah you could eat come on mm-hmm what
do you want say food
sit good girl
you guys still here there's no way
you're still watching this video thanks
for watching